[Music]
max versus Vanessa they're rumoured Feud
on the dance floor's now taken up Barry
returned yet appeared that Max was
putting it all behind them when he
posted an apology to Vanessa
saying quote I take full responsibility
for my absence but now a source claims
that it was all just smoke and mirrors
that fixes image quote max is in
full-blown crisis management mode
he's losing fans and is getting tons of
negative press so he's trying to win
people back you know ever since we heard
things got heated between Max and
Vanessa and that they have clashed at
the beginning but nASA has stayed
relatively quiet
a few of Max's other partners have been
vocal about their past battles you miss
working with I don't miss the rehearsals
at all our source says the big
difference now with Vanessa is she isn't
afraid to stand up to him so could they
end up switching partners that's
unlikely because according to our source
quote drama is expected and part of the
show it's a lot of pressure on us more
work than I've ever had to do before
but as Max also facing off against
Dancing's producers while one source
tells ET he's quote on thin ice another
refutes that calling max a professional
listen I'm not trying to do this whole
Dancing with the Stars feel and say the
right things with all due respect this
is my show you know I helped make it
what it is
the feisty 37 year old has had issues
with producers and judges before I've
been in this business for nearly 50
years
- octogenarian the judge is different
i'ma go outside because I'm about to
punch something in the wall we've even
shown him some of his outbursts a lot of
it was just passion to the full type of
things
despite his passion max has been asked
back for 17 seasons now and while one
source tells us he'll be on his best
behavior from here on out another source
maintains max remains in good standing
with the show yesterday is why PETA was
busy with Vanessa's hobby NIC and
rehearsals their spouses were back in
the studio today vanessa telling us
saying
so going really well well prettiest
thing that they will dance the Rumba on
Monday night and it's to her husband
Nick song Godspeed
[Music]